jean or on sait aujourd'hui qu'à moins
d'arriver à 80% de vaccination on aura
pas d' immunité collective donc
conclusion ce jour là vous aurez un co
vide qui va durer durer durer durer
alors pas moins d'une vidéo n'est pas du
tout d'accord fabrizio comme d'hab alors
non c'est les armes et c'est que d'abord
ça marche pas la russie essayait par
exemple la russie sait pas comment
vacciner les gens parce que concrètement
ils veulent passer à vacciner parce
qu'ils disent c'est la même conditionnel
on sait pas trop on va attendre un peu
donc elle a dit on va offrir des glaces
aux enfants on va offrir un savoir faire
est assez bonne et non mais non pas aux
etats unis c'est pas vrai tu es
seulement la virginie au passage puis
deux autres éléments
ça porte un nom ça ça porte un nom ce
que tu dis là s'appelle de la corruption
c'est le mot le mot qui convient à la
production prenons maintenant c'est quoi
un tibet c'est le cas j'appelle ça un
site à nantua vous haïssez s'en tape
connaissent exactement sa récitation de
l'eau sont des copines quand quelqu'un
ne veut pas faire quelque chose et
vénère et que je veux effectivement
qu'il le fasse
qu'est ce que je fais soit je le contre
un soir où l'influent fils fabrice
hamaide votre métier enfin je termine
cette avocate ce dernier de tourner les
choses pour gagner un pur non non non
non non non non non non c'est vrai est
autre chose dans cette histoire et deux
autres choses importantes
d'abord c'est très intéressant vous avez
dit un truc extrêmement intéressant vous
avez dit tous les milieux sociaux
culturels défavorisés c'est top
déjà c'est génial j'aime beaucoup cette
idée j'aime beaucoup cette idée que en
gros les pauvres on va les inciter à se
faire vacciner avec 25 ou 30 du matin
mais je crois qu'elle a réussi un majeur
c'est juste sur ce point je voulais un
truc les mecs comme moi elle a foot de
voir vincent balle 200 balles 150 balles
j ai rien à [ __ ] mais version foot
pourquoi rien à [ __ ] parce que je suis
pas 150 balles près donc le mec peut pas
faire vacciner le mec qui veut pas se
faire vacciner
concrètement et on va la cité à exercer
sa liberté avec un avantage économique
mais je trouve sur la dernière
alors gilles verdez où vous êtes
d'accord avec journée totalement pour en
plus la serbie est à l'arrêt au niveau
de la vaccination il faut savoir que 25
euros ces 5 % du salaire moyen
c'est très incitatif c'est très malin
c'est intelligent et c'est pas du tout
une contrainte de la corruption alors
que nancy n'a su offre d anneau dans le
nez des mixeurs oui aux etats unis ils
offrent des cadeaux nouveau vallorcine
par canal inverse est ce qu'une averse
est possible attentat réussi ce à quoi
on veut valoriser les gens connaissent
moins finir pourquoi on veut vacciner
gens pas seulement pour les protéger
mais pour y noter que eux soit dit c'est
le genre et le chalet d'une maladie
chaîne il ya deux choses je veux dire
ils étaient deux choses distinctes
je te pose une question qui est
relativement simple ténue tri sioniste
est ce que demain je doit inciter
financièrement les gens a pas acheté
d'alcool a pas acheté de malbouffe est
ce que je dois inciter financièrement
les gens c'est à dire djaber c'est à
dire que en fait quel est ce pays et
quel est ce monde d'après où on pense
que l'argent devient m on avoue mis
quelques années payer des lycéens
société qu'à salt dans ses nouveaux
locaux avec fabrice do with by juju
d'accord effectivement d'abord en france
on a une très belle sécurité sociale
mais franchement je commandais demandé à
donner 25 euros pour aller encourager
les danseurs vacciner c'est qu'on a
toujours raté depuis des mois les sujets
les gars mais six compositions de bach
saint divy balle plus 25 balles ça coûte
pas un bras de milliers amplement faut
pas déconner ou alors les noms vaccins
pour les installateurs d'un médecin pour
le covoiturage